if you're looking forward to horizon  zero dawn you can now get an early look  at the full world map I'm Tony and this  GameSpot news update may contain some  spoilers game revolution uploaded the  map which shows the major regions and a  few landmarks the game seems to have  three major areas mother's heart  Meridian and Sun fall distinct shades of  green brown and white can also be seen  on the map but we don't know if this  implies different terrain or something  else we also don't know the full scale  of the map  aka how big the world actually is  horizon zero dawn comes exclusively to  ps4 on February 28th we recently got  hands-on with the game and you can hear  us discuss it on the lobby  GameSpot's weekly live show every  Wednesday at 11:00 a.m. Pacific and to  keep up with all the latest on ps4  exclusives you're already in the right  place  you